you know Haryana you're a woman I can't
believe exists yeah a good way and my
name is Arianna Arianna badassery I'm
Gregory 14 woman you won't believe exist
a list here from keeping it Karl a lot
of you eighteen over eighteen mill
eighteen million views over well Matt
like people are really into woman it's a
popular topic today we look at fourteen
women you won't believe they exist these
unusual and amazing women will surprise
you number fourteen Ellis ami de Silva
born in nineteen ninety five is the
tallest teen in the world at six feet
nine inches she grew so tall because of
a tumor on a pituitary gland which
doctors haven't removed she is engaged
to her boyfriend who was only five foot
four inches tall
number thirteen would you believe there
was someone born in the eighteen
hundreds still alive today I knew well
Misao Okawa was born in 1898 and is
currently 116 years old four year what's
your secret this will blow your mind
eat and sleep but she does also say to
learn to relax the oldest known person
to ever live was a French woman who
lived to a hundred and twenty-two years
old
well vaudeville venus palermo aka Venus
angelic born in 1997 insulin is so now
from her close resemblance to a doll
through a combination of makeup and
special circle contact lenses she's able
to achieve a very doll-like appearance
she has a YouTube channel where she
gives makeup tutorials number 11
Julia ganucci aka The Illustrated lady
has the world record for being the most
tattooed person in the world she has 95%
of her body covered what's interesting
about her besides the tattoos is the
reason she got them she has a skin
condition called porphyria which causes
blisters on her skin when it's exposed
to light she got used to cover up the
blisters Oh number 10
this is Yaya Han and whoa rabbit Yaya
participates in what is known as cosplay
which is a word to rhyme yeah we know
come on oh gosh Russia as fictional
characters there are cosplay conventions
around the world and people usually
dress up as comic book science fiction
anime or video game characters besides
being a cosplayer model she is also a
costume designer having treated almost
when selling kind of love she has
cosplay
she makes in his eyes woman chun-li from
Street Fighter and many more but it's
not like the most unique thing red
polish strong woman and is the
winningest chocolate in the world she
benches 297 pounds squats 540 oh my god
vital record for frying pan rolling
rolling five pans in a minute she bro
loves his Frank man Mandela has the
world's record for longest dreadlocks
just how they're exercising 19 feet 6
inches and they weighed 39 pounds
ouch reportedly measures 55 feet long
she's been growing that for 25 years how
does she carry them around she has a
special bag she wears over her shoulders
to stop the dreads in this guy versa a
German woman named Michelle Cobden Oh
Keith a 16 inch waist by wearing a
corset for three years her dream is to
have a 15 inch waist
it ruins your organization oh we have
the world record for widest hips at 5
feet 4 inches tall her hips measure an
unbelievable 8 feet in circumference to
have irregardless
her waist is only 40 inches at 420
pounds she drives a truck because she
can't fit in a car and
to often walk through doors sideways she
says her husband Reggie is her biggest
fan uh-huh ever but ITA allagadda a is
an Ethiopian woman who has the largest
lip disk in the world measuring seven
point six inches across the discs are
considered way of impacting a husband in
order to get the disc women have their
bottom two party knocked out
number four Valerio lukayla
AKA human bargain iran in 1985 in
moldova is famous for her pictures in
which she looks like a human Barbie doll
what you may not know about her is that
she said she's a professional mountain
climber
apparently she also has a new-age
spiritual side she is a teacher at the
school of out-of-body travel and was
featured in a documentary called space
Barbie some people think that she has
had surgery to remove some of her ribs
to give her a tinier waist she denies
this saying she has only had breast
augmentation
that's where everything yeah number
three Mandy Sellars was born in 1975
even at birth she had very large feet
and it was evident that something was
wrong
her legs continued to grow at an
abnormal rate in 2009 was estimated her
legs alone weighed 210 pounds and that
her upper body weighed only 84 pounds
her condition is believed to be caused
by a gene mutation in 2010 she had to
have her left foot amputated number 2
charity Pierce is the world's heaviest
woman at 765 pound
you might think a 765 pound women would
be singled but you'd be wrong
in fact at age 38 charity has a 22
year-old fiancé Tony Sauer who she said
she'd had sex with four times a day in
the beginning of their late
interestingly she has a daughter not
from her fiancé Tony but from her
fiance's older brother
Ginny ha and now for the number one
woman he won't believe exists for more
videos like this subscribe here number
one Joe TM gay born in 1998 is an Indian
map my smallest woman measuring only two
feet tall her height is caused by a form
of dwarfism called achondroplasia both
her parents are normal height if you
hear her talk she sounds like a chipmunk
Jodi was in the fourth season of
American Horror Story yeah she is taller
than the shortest man in the world
tender bangy who stands at one foot nine
and a half inches tall which woman was
the hardest for you to believe exists
hey guys thanks so much for watching my
Jewish video I really appreciate it if
you're new here subscribe check out my
earlier video I did on men you all
believe exist
Alice on e Silva she's 21 years old
she's 21
she's very tall I'm mostly why is she
already engaged
I mean her legs yeah I mean it's really
like why no rush you're six foot nine
you had things to do
and he's five for two makes it funny
here yeah it's like she could have
probably dated like a 6-foot even three
or four guy I mean it's pretty romantic
I meet a lot of people where height is a
really bit like that matters like you
wouldn't would you date someone shorter
than me my height maybe yeah cuz you're
pretty you're generally five eight I'm
not as tall as I feel like people think
oh really funny hearing myself so yes oh
I think you're a lot taller than that
there are ten hits Ivy I don't think I
could date a woman taller than me really
how tall are you yeah probably could I'm
five ten you thought I was your height
yeah thought really it's same height for
some reason it's a good thing is it look
at you in the eyes when I talk to you
well yeah and know that like height
really doesn't matter your height
matters losing Kevin Hart and his wife
well Kevin Hart makes up for it by being
hilarious love Kevin Hart penny a moment
I can just bring him up something tells
me look at this guy he's a funny guy
he's making her laugh and it's this
thing he's my make her fall over thing
hmm what's that tell people with small
penises and small people with tall with
long penises sometimes this house
explains my friend Brandon donger miss
our Okawa hump Tina was so cute I love
her I have read the Old Testament well
not really I read the action Bible of
the Old Testament
it's a comic book interpretation of back
then people live to be like eight
hundred years old seven hundred years
old Allah no not a comic book this is
how was in the Old Testament like the
Bible okay fine the fact that she lived
to be a hundred sixteen so far
impressive but not impressed
I feel like somewhere down the line us
human beings believe that we would die
younger so we now don't get to live as
long it's a belief and I believe that if
I can believe I what about and the olden
days
who would I like 40 didn't know what was
happening they didn't know the devil and
he was done there's history to back all
this up she looks like if the Joker was
still living he's really cute I feel
like she is uh like a evil Japanese mob
boss could not be more cuddly seeming
she's wearing like pastel colors she
seems like a mob boss you're wrong
well here's the thing my grandma was
actually Filipino she passed away a
couple years ago and she does kind of
remind me of her so that was me using my
defense mechanisms so vulnerable see
Japanese they know what to do ma'am they
got a damn Japanese know how to live and
you're going to do the oxygen Japan you
gotta meet up with Misawa okaaaaay
okaaaaay yeah you gotta meet up with her
man tell you saw her on YouTube you want
her autograph you can do reaction with
her what if on the reaction is that's
what you know we're not gonna go that
learn we're not gonna go that dork venus
palermo Venus angelic holy crap does she
really look like a doll it's kind of
crazy
it's weird a so big I don't know where
she's from but speaking of Japan is like
a whole Lolita style like dressed like a
doll thing and that's really popular in
Harajuku or Sheree style really mastered
it yeah she looks like it like something
you see like it it's insidious movie I
can see a lot of guys really being into
that kind of style yeah those guys are
good yeah cuz you know I know that when
I was a boy I used to find like some
dolls to be hot but then I grew up and
realized that's for kids so I can see
some boys being into her who probably
get her the balls probably haven't
dropped yet but good for you Venus yeah
seems like yeah but really I mean she's
really pretty
it's just I'd be scared if I was around
her I don't like things that are from
the unknown this one's pretty
high-maintenance
me know she's very
I mean it you think sort of makeup and
costuming and eyelashes and see I think
it's impressive that she can do that art
like she's she's her own piece of art
and I'm not someone who would really
judge someone like this however judge
everyone I don't judge everyone
literally your job however if she lives
her life looking like this like on the
daily I wouldn't be able she does I want
to be able dater you're missing out
Venus what do you look like under the
doll makeup Julia good news news yes I
can see you doing that
taching your whole body up if I could
provide you with any money like as much
money as you want it to get whatever
tattoo you wanted what would you get I'm
not good at this you're not gonna now
I'd say what I get well you get an
emergency aid sign what to know that I'm
always there for you it's all that's
spreading love
I've gotten used to me saying weird
things I say hide nothing all right he's
a gentleman
okay waiting for that so she has a
disease where she can't go in the Sun
for free that's that's so sad I'm so
grateful right now that I can go in the
Sun I love the Sun really I love this
Sun they're like a little browner don't
look a little browner I was in the Sun a
lot this weekend yeah that's true huh
and zone looking a little browner no I
usually don't like getting like tan and
then looking brown and stuffing and
someone told me anything that should
embrace the fact that I'm able to ten
that a lot of people can't tan and that
I can't and that makes your skin
actually look better yeah it's not good
for your skin but you know it's worse
tagging up your whole body
have you seen hoop what's he who's
framing Roger Rabbit no that's the
character from his friend no I know who
she is and she was hot that animation
right I know I couldn't believe it
I guess not a few years ago I was like I
think makes us an animated girls so
[ __ ] hot I think that's really the
way to make but she looks so much better
animated as animated girl than she does
is real herself which is sad I mean
she's still pretty I just would look at
the other version more basically I
wouldn't want you to be your real self
all the time play Jessica Rabbit and
that s Flora's Forks
she's buff I can't believe old pans what
does that mean frying pans look you
actually won't even picture of her with
the pan rolling at oh man that's a fry
notice the pan she rolled five of them
is the fastest frying pan roller which
is the thing I guess whoa could you roll
one frying pan go get a frying pan but
it has me one you don't like thank you
switch in case we actually cheap your
gold show them it's a very small pan
okay okay you're like impressed
I mean that's not easy or necessary ever
to do oh wait this is my good pan the
other one was on the bottom drawer what
the unroll it I can't undo it that's way
more work is it I just feel a week now
for some piece here you unroll it I did
workout today
oh yeah but can you believe you can do
it just roll the other side in see if
you get rolling you kind of did it you
did it see all to make you guys
entertain Wow I don't know in my [ __ ]
can for you that was amazing
see you accomplished something today Wow
five tabs out of nothing look at that I
don't like the dreads I don't like that
one bit ones like the dreads years and
years of dreads that she carries in a
purse I just don't like the idea that's
39 pounds yeah I don't like
aesthetically I could see how you like
some people would like that or you might
dig it but the idea that's like why
would you like carry around 79 extra
pounds on your head in a purse
everywhere you go that's crazy that's
not mine not be good for your back and
rear it's definitely not good
hear about oh my god Shh actually
whatever your name is I'm sorry for you
I'm sorry with you definitely a choice
it's definitely a choice I'm sorry for
you well you shouldn't be sorry for her
if it's a choice I guess Michelle Sookie
sure we got to talk about this waist
training [ __ ] up your inside it's a
fact three people do that like oh hello
all the Kardashians all the Instagram
well they just wear a corsage straight
course that of course massage yeah so
very course that eventually like you're
how long you were the corset for me and
people workout and then people sleep and
then people go out and then I mean she
this girl I believe where as one call it
every day the last three years I should
probably wear one it [ __ ] up your like
insides like different it's not
necessary man around why would you do
that why have a tiny
waste it's a really old school like I
remember Pirates of the Caribbean and
the deafening tears because who weren't
getting enough oxygen and they're
passing out it's just not necessary
Michelle you got a great body you've
achieved something well enough stop
trying to get more it's really I
personally would not I mean I think I I
don't want to judge and save and secure
things but seems like it just saying
it's not good for you or anything you
might communication you say they were
but it's taking back everything you say
before yeah my mom doesn't less say but
really I trust me however Mikkel
ruffinelli I love how happy your husband
is her husband's like I scored the
jackpot that's beautiful
I'm going to doors and driving a car is
pretty important tool to do and she has
to drive a truck does she have a
condition or she nope
they didn't say that so she's just very
like fortunate when turn capacitors
you're the 40 inch waist Wow which is
you know not huge compared to her hips
but some guys like asses and hips black
guys look at her husband it's not but
though yes this is all going out its
going wide true this you're right prices
I wouldn't want it thank you Ariane
you're welcome I'm learning to clear up
my thoughts at ie alia get Dagny
different culture it's a different thing
you do you she had her two front teeth
removes oh that's still an order of no I
like my two front teeth is it like some
type of cultural thing more definitely
they even say that is to attract a
husband so she probably has all know her
pick of the litter
Wow some people are really interested in
different things in other countries see
there you go it's a different cultures
different culture no need to judge no
need to judge no need I just think that
uh-huh but good I think however not for
me it's not for me
for you do you look Larry up girl I mean
I've seen her before in different
reality type show thing uh-huh
it's like contacts and it's her whole
body face like our whole body just looks
like a doll it's looks like a mannequin
yeah I don't know those are huge
implants for her body but you know what
she likes them and I mean now she's like
spiritual which is you know a weird man
cool I mean she looks real in this photo
but in like these other ones it just
looks like a blow-up sighs oh I did it
that photos probably very edited Oh
Mandy Sellars dude she could be a
superhero
where Mandy that's a condition that's a
big conditioner what he imagine them
having that big of feet I'm already
insecure about my toes and you get a
pedicure do you get pedicures I want to
they're great
yeah I really ever liked what a lot of
guys have had a curious I'm not like
objecting against it I want to get one
charity Pierce has a baby from her
fiance's older brother yeah and they
used to have sex with her new fiance
four times a day
sounds like she's the charity that
they're giving to it's not healthy it's
not healthy but you know like some guys
they like it she's a mother
did she even know she was pregnant sure
way to know if you're that happy
well I mean I know there's a way to know
when like is it like easy to become like
oh you should have all right is that
show I didn't know I was pregnant yeah
I'm a lot of those people like not
necessarily are fat and don't realize it
or some of them just stay thin and don't
realize it so sometimes the weight gain
is different for everyone
and the way it shows on our body is
different god I would love to just like
look at everyone in the world died like
everyone okay you my brother Mary ever
got it your top two I would just eat
myself to just obesity just huge like
like turbulence so it's like last man on
earth last man on earth you what are you
gonna do I'm gonna eat as much food as I
can I'll eat myself to death or or yeah
yes
I would find travel the world for one
other human being bad start I would use
a car or a fly a plane okay but how are
you gonna it's a lot of issues with this
plan I'll take this subway who's
operating the subway Oh figure out
operate the subway also that's your plan
you're the last man on earth you're
gonna get on the subway what would the
average person do so you're gonna do the
most average thing not the most average
it's actually opposite the app if you
think you can figure out how to run the
subway you don't think you can do like a
private plane
yeah probably could so why don't you
just go straight to that more dangerous
zombies flied this world I have this
whole story would say yeah I understand
this a lot I didn't realize about your
generality I'm honestly I would I mean I
saw her an American Horror Story
I would think she's just an adorable
little girl no you would not I thought
she wasn't I saw her right now really I
didn't know as a woman until he said it
was a woman yeah I thought it was just a
kid yeah she's like an adorable kid I
would adopt you
you're probably older than me but I
would adopt you are you in the market
for adopting yeah yeah no you're not yes
I am no you're not I want to adopt so
many right now yes you're lying
yeah the economy stuff he's lying kids
are so high these days you got oh
they're so high right Isis is spring
kids Oh God despite this here market is
probably value really badly well weird I
gotta end this video now we're gonna see
Ariane pee on my couch subscribe to the
reject channel her name is Arianna
Basara hi and I want to give a quick
shout out to to uh one of these things
one of these ladies
Ellis Ani watch your step take